we want the fetchweathertask to return
an array of string forecasts this means
we need to modify the return type of the
async task to be a string array the
effect of this is that the do and
background method will now return a
string array in this method after we
query the server and then read in the
input stream we're going to perform this
code to parse the response from the
server we call get weather data from
JSON and we pass in the forecast JSON
string as well as the number of forecast
days to make sure that this is returning
the right string array we can go into
the method and then at the bottom of the
method which is add some logging
statements to print out every element of
the string array now when you compile
the code and run it on your device you
can hit the refresh button to pull the
data from the server then if you open up
logcat you can see that it was parsed
correctly where you see all the forecast
entries being printed out